um 1631 e4 is our move
and i'm tired of the c3 sicilian so
let's play mainline we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna do mainline stuff and
i'm going to introduce you guys to a
line that i i play
full-time when i play one e4 and that's
called the rosso limo
and the rosso limo it's a very
misunderstood
opening because people think of this as
the ray lopez or people are you just
playing the spanish
remember the blacks played the sicilian
so you can't
take one opening and name
a different opening the same opening
because if black played a different move
the nature of the position is going to
be different
so we're going to play the move bishop
b5 this is a move played very very
commonly at the top level
[Music]
uh and not as
and not as much at i would say the club
player level really not as much because
it's quite difficult to understand some
of the ideas it's very positional
and uh it's a little bit less intuitive
than the rye lopez and the rye lopez the
reason you play this move is to put
pressure on the e5 pawn if you think
about it
right you want to take the knight at
some point and attack the pawn
in the rosalina you're not there's no
pawn to attack why are you putting the
bishop here you're really putting the
bishop here to take the knight
that's essentially the point and the
move a6 is a waste of time
because in many lines you take the
knight of your own free will this is a
waste of a tempo
and the consequence of this is that
black has damage to spawn structure
and i've railed on for game after game
about how pawn structure isn't that
important which is exactly why i don't
often recommend the rosso limo
to people in the 16 1700 range you
should either play the c3 sicilian
or you should play the open sicilian
just play d4
but i still want to introduce you to
some of the high level logic behind
these openings because they can be
helpful even if you don't play the the
openings
and uh this pawn structure deficiency is
kind of a big deal at a high level
because you know not to sound
condescending you know like gm's know
how to punish
how to exploit it uh and it takes a lot
of positional finesse
some of this even i don't have which is
why i i don't
i sometimes play the sidelines within
the russell email so let's begin by
developing first of all we need to
castle
nothing happens here without castling
now
how should white handle black's pawn
structure what is what does it even mean
to exploit
this uh damaged pawn structure
oftentimes what you'll see is that when
you and i don't know all of these ideas
so
we might not be playing in the best way
one of the things that we can do the
simplest idea this can be borrowed from
the rye lopez
is to control the center because when we
control the center
let's imagine that this c pawn was go
let's imagine this pawn was gone
this pawn on c6 would kind of be weak
the pawn on a6 would kind of be weak so
it would be easier to access
uh the pawns that are left behind and
there's a very simple idea here that you
see
very commonly in the rye lopez that
seems
particularly good here but before we
play it
in the rosalie mode is often a very good
idea to prevent the bishop from coming
out to g4
that is just an automatic move in most
positions in the russolimo
okay knight f6 so he's attacking the
pawn we should defend it
e5 is interesting but it gives the
knight a very nice central square on d5
i think it's premature
the idea that i was talking about is of
course c3d4 so what move should we play
here
to not interfere with our plan of going
c3d4
how should we knowing that we're going
to play c3 we shouldn't play knight c3
we should play rookie one yes slightly
violating the rule that you should
defend with the lowest value piece but
we are trying to go
okay he's playing very quickly here and
very sloppily that
castles was a big mistake he's allowing
us to make more weaknesses what should
we do now
it's not a hook because he's not going
to castle long i mean look at his queen
side
so he's not going to attack us on the
king's side any time soon
so it's 95 i think you guys are going
for the
the tempting move but again if he's got
95 just take the pawn
just take the pawn now look at this
disaster that's happening on the queen
side
and this disaster is very easy to attack
the bishop's going to come out here
eventually and attack this pawn
now where should we put our queen you
should always be looking for those
squares that are out of the way
you know in a little cul-de-sac
somewhere
you know not interfering with any of the
other pieces but also doing something
but also doing something preferably
of an attacking nature so don't settle
on c2
let's go to a4 because it's it's
protecting this one but it's also
attacking
c6 this is an ideal square for the queen
the queen is often very well placed on
the edges of the board because it's hard
to attack
and it doesn't always sacrifice quality
because the queen is still doing a lot
unlike a knight the queen doesn't sort
of not control squares just because it's
on the edge
all right queen b6 now i'm looking at
his queen and i'm saying okay the screen
is very vulnerable in many different
ways
we need to eventually develop these two
pieces they're not developed yet
in what order well if we bring our
bishop out we obviously lose the pawn on
b2
i think some people would play b3 at
this point but that's very weakening
because that allows this bishop on g7 to
get very nice control over the diagonal
so one maneuver that those with good
positional understanding we'll see
is knight a3 to c4 knight a3 very nice
everybody's
most people are seeing it pretty quickly
maybe maybe not knight c4 immediately
but that's the ultimate idea we go
knight c4 attack the queen defend the
pawn
pave the way for the bishop coming out
but maybe not yet we'll see
whether we can refine this because
and this is where things get
positionally complex knight c4
is a mistake here it is a mistake it's
premature and we should begin i think by
chasing this bishop out of e6 with
knight g5
so we're going to play this move because
we're pretty slow
but think about it and then after the
game we will
revisit this moment and talk about why
knight c4 is bad this is a very
instructive moment in my opinion
it shows the intersection of positional
thinking and tactics
well knight d2 blocks the bishop that's
the only reason
it would have probably led to the same
thing oh now look at what he allows us
to do look at his pawns
this is pretty epic this is pretty epic
okay um
now how should we what should we
do again knight c4 is extremely tempting
but i believe that it's not the best
move amazingly i know that
sounds crazy but we we have to answer
why and we'll we'll talk more about this
after the game
yeah queen c4 is what i like the best
the most
the problem with knight c4 and we have
to answer this question
is that black is this incredibly
annoying move queen to b5
and our queen is under fire if we take
his queen we allow him to correct his
pawn structure which is a really big
deal i don't want to let him
fix all of his pawn structure
deficiencies on the queen side that's
what we're trying to attack
and it's extremely hard to we can play
queen b3 there
um and try to trade on our own terms so
black is going to try to trade on his
terms he's going to give us a counter
offer
and uh you know the asking price there
is too high
so instead if we pay attention to this
e6 pawn
we can just drag our queen over to c4
it's a very awkward looking move
but it's very strong because he barely
can defend the spot he can go rook f6
obviously we can go e5 in response to
that just attack the rook
all right so when they're this when
there are so many
weaknesses in a position just abandon
you know your move shouldn't have to
look good it doesn't have to look good
just look at ways to attack the
weaknesses all right
put aside considerations about well does
this move
follow the rules at this point it's time
to put your concrete thinking hat on and
take all of his pieces
all right so he's just starting to to to
give up everything
c4 is now he lets us put the knight on t
i assumed he wanted to maybe sack the
queen on f2 but it doesn't do anything
we still have to be careful our queen is
a little bit uh
a little bit stuck on d7 so
what should we do here we've got a
couple of possible moves we also need to
be very mindful of bishop h4 as a
potential threat
we we need to first and foremost ask
ourselves
is he threatening to trap the queen is
this a priority do we need to bring the
queen back to d3
because if we bring back the queen to d3
he does have bishop h4
that's a tiny bit concerning i'm going
to play this move anyway because i see a
response to bishop h4 if he plays it
we'll have a chance to find that
response
because bishop h4 puts three attackers
on the f2 pawn and only one defender
just mathematically there's no way to
defend that pawn but what we can do is
we can soften the blow
he doesn't do it this allows us to just
get our bishop out an event
this is the move we would have played
even if he would have played bishop h4
by the way
this should be three queen b5 let's go
a4 let's just get his queen out of there
it's probably gonna go here
and i have a really sick idea i have a
really cool idea if you go screen b3 i
really hope he does
because not only is this okay he doesn't
damn
okay that's fine so
not much that we have to do here we
simply
have to identify pieces that we haven't
brought in we have many good moves
what's an example of a good
sort of solid move bringing the last
piece into the game
so bishop d4 would allow e5 you could
shut down that trade opportunity
i would just go rook at e1 i would play
it very methodically
if he goes rogue da we can take the rook
and take the rest of his pieces
we will have two rooks and two pieces
for the queen that is
that is just completely winning this
bishop h6 so he's trying to trade on his
own
i mean sure thank you
absolutely okay now again it's important
not to overthink these things
knight e5 is good bring our queen into
the game with queen d7
let's get queen g3 we can sort of limit
the mobility of his queen
and pave the way for rook to d7 that's
just one way of playing it one of many
he is winning on time that's true we
could treat queens we don't have to
there's no need to i'm
almost struggling because of how many
good moves there are
let's begin with the move rooks e3 maybe
we'll get it to f3
and offer the trade of rooks yeah 95 is
fine i just didn't want to give up the
b2 pawn
it's not a big deal either way it's
completely winning but
we're going to lift our rook and either
trade rooks or
you know one of whatever is going to
happen is going to be good for us
suffering from success yeah this is not
a very interesting part of the game
you can just practice these kinds of
things with a computer for example you
just set it up
and and and you know set up a position
where you're up like a queen or
something and
just practice some raps now here we have
a nice tactic
okay found it
nice little fork with a nice little
touch at the end because he does have
queen e6
i wonder who saw that who saw that he
could play queen e6 counter-attack the
rook
who can tell me the entire line now what
should we do here
should we take the rook do we have
another move
here the 15-second rule should be
applied don't stop calculating when it
seems
like the position may have taken a turn
for the worse we can play queen e5
and trade queens nicely done to spot it
but we can take first
and then play queen e5 and then
checkmate him on g7 and that's game over
okay
yeah plethora that's right boom
okay and we're over 1600 great
so sorry
okay so um that was a nice game
and the russolima is named after
nicholas nicholas rossolimo
who um who was a as a very interesting
life story peter did a lecture on him
originally born in france i think in
1890 moved to new york
worked as a taxi driver he had his own
chess store i mean
very colorful character but that's for
another uh
we'll save that for another time and
people often play bishop b5 not because
they want to play the russolimo
but because they think they're playing
the right lopez so this does happen
sometimes in beginner games
when people play with should be five
things i'm playing the ray lopez it was
first played in 1851 russell limo was
far from the first one
to play this move and in the very first
game
where this was featured black by the way
was
van cruise and van croy's
sort of quote-unquote invented e3 which
is sometimes called the van cruz
game or the van cruz defense not a
you know not a very memorable
contribution to opening theory but
nonetheless
and vancouver's played a6 so a6 is an
instinctive move if you're used to
playing this in the rye lopez
right but it's it's a waste of time
because white
takes this knight anyway so the main
moves here are g6 you can play the
accelerated dragon way
you can play e6 so you can play the same
moves you would make against d4
right and all of these moves are
sensible d6 is a little bit more
you know pushing it a little bit but
it's perfectly legitimate as i play d6
with black
when i go into this position um there is
even knight f6 sort of an alakan
alakine like id although it's a little
bit you know not as fashionable
and there's a few very fringe moves
there's knight d4 there's even that a5
has been played against me
um so a6 takes takes
yeah and in the main line
you know white sometimes castles if you
watch my games you'll see that i played
the sort of hybrid between
the alepan and the rosalina i like the
move c3 which has become popular
recently vodka thank you for the pride
but the main line is to take on c6 both
dc and bc
are possible dc is more common opening
up the bishop
and white almost always plays h3 to stop
bishop g4 and you get this very
very well-known structure the rossolimo
structure
um and it's very interesting black is
the two bishops
but he's got this sort of reminds you of
the exchange ray lopez right
uh where white can attack these pawns in
a variety of ways black can play king's
indian
style moving the knight away and going
f5 i myself have very unfamiliar with
the theory here
black can also go e5 creating the sort
of marotzi bind
bishop g4 is not really a threat it's
just that this bishop often doesn't find
a good place like if you think about it
like where is this bishop going to
develop
do you see a good spot for it because i
don't it's just sort of sitting there
it's good that black has the two bishops
but as of now this bishop just doesn't
have a good place to go to
um so it's not that it's a positional
threat and positional threats are not
threats to win material but threats to
do something
that's positionally or strategically
good so just trade off a favorable piece
right so again we're operating here in a
completely positional level nothing here
is
tactical or immediate yeah you can play
bc and take toward the center
but then you get the sort of damaged
bond structure that we saw in our game
and
this can be hard to deal with so again i
don't want to delve too deeply into the
theory
you can search youtube introduction to
russell
i'm sure you can find some videos and
stuff but that's the bottom line it's a
super positional line
okay so a6 takes takes we castle
so here we went h3 i wasn't planning to
but yeah then i realized
again look at this bishop it can't go to
f5 it can't go to g4
yeah what is it doing here it literally
has no good place it's a funny situation
you don't get this too often
where a piece just doesn't have a good
spot to develop to
the russolima is kind of unique in this
way
i guess in the french black buries his
own bishop
here um uh oh it's clipping
okay let me just lower the gain
yeah here it's very very hard to to get
the bishop anywhere
okay so knight f6 rookie one
um yeah and so the question here is well
he castled he made it very easy for us
of course we should play cd
or black should play cd and doesn't this
undouble
black's pawns well yes it does but
everything is a balance right the first
thing to notice is that we get a very
nice pawn center very nicely supported
by pieces
the other thing i pointed out is that
even though it undoubles black spawns
black still has two pawn weaknesses on
the queen side
both of them are relatively accessible
you can play queen a4 you can play queen
c2
and you know and and target the pawn
straight away
and the third thing is that y can create
further
pawn structure weaknesses why can go e5
why just has a very nice position don't
overthink this
black has a hard time developing this
bishop why it's got a nice center
black's got pawn weaknesses
that's it i'm seeing what you're seeing
i'm not seeing anything else
bishop g5 or c1 super easy natural play
black is cramped bond weaknesses and no
clear
plan of action no clear way of
developing this bishop anywhere good
so it's you know it's a good edge for
white white isn't white it's not winning
but white is clearly better here
so our opponent played instantly he
castles takes takes
it's way too early to talk about
converting way too early
right you just it like if you talk about
this position
white is clearly better but you would
make all the good moves here bishop g5
rook c1
queen d2 bishop h6 is always a plan to
consider here just to eliminate this
bishop
you would be looking in positions for
like e5 at the right moment
maybe e5 pawn break when the bishop is
here to target that pawn there's a
million things you could do
um and you need to be patient with
yourself
in terms of developing mastery in those
positions they're hard to convert for
sure
okay so takes takes we go queen a4 again
looking for the best square it's out of
the way
attack the pawn queen b6 knight a3
yeah so the only reason i didn't go here
is because it blocks the bishop that may
end up not being important
in the grand scheme of things but why
limit yourself
bishop b6 is is is not a bad move
and a lot of people would play knight c4
here
this is a big mistake due to queen b5 so
what's going on here
well there's contact between the queens
and white has no choice in this position
but to trade queens
because the knight is being attacked
from two different places
so after takes takes black no longer has
any pawn structure weaknesses and he
still has the two bishops now this
bishop all of a sudden has come out to a
good spot
black is better right so things change
in an instant
that is one of the reasons why beginners
intermediate players find it easier to
deal with tactics because
when you are trying to nurse a
positional advantage
everything could be ruined in a single
move like a pawn structure deficiency
could be corrected you could allow your
opponent to undouble
or get active and then everything
dissipates so quickly
positional advantages are very fragile
right they're like
you know they're like air bubbles you
have to be
or sky walls okay terrible you have to
be very careful about how you handle
them
and tactics is a bridge that allows
somebody
to reverse a positional disadvantage and
make it into a positional advantage
which is exactly what happens here
right this is this is using the tactics
using the not fancy tactics but the
queen
being hanging the fact that it's hang is
the tactical property of the position
the move b3 would not be good here
you know right because it it it opens up
the diagonal for the bishop
anyways i don't want to belabor the
point now he played knight d7 this is
basically a decisive mistake
of course he had to move his bishop back
as unpleasant as it is
now knight c4 is still not ideal
i wouldn't rush with it um
what should we do here
what should we do here
yeah so bishop e3 he can take the pawn
i'm afraid
did you guys find a way to trap the
queen because i'm not seeing it
i'm not seeing a way to trap the queen
if there was a way to trap the queen
here i'd go for this
but if there wasn't i wouldn't risk it
although you can play knights i mean
white is still dominating even without
these pawns
i would just go e5 yeah i would shove
this through
all the way to e6 just take
and look at this this is just this is
equally as good as the game
black would not um black maybe should go
back to c8 honestly just not to allow e6
with tempo
but now already bishop e3 looks a lot
more appealing
because well you have this move with
tempo at some i don't want to i'm too
lazy to calculate right now
i've done enough of that against hal but
you know what you understand what i'm
saying i think
now this move allows queen c4 the game
is over after this move
he even if he didn't blunder his knight
he would have to give up this pawn
and his other pods would fall like
dominoes
so basically the only thing to avoid
here is this automatic move knight c4
and how do you know to check for queen
b5 the thing that makes knight c4 less
appealing to me
is that you have to go back for a second
ask yourself
wait wait don't i don't i'm not i'm
finishing after this game guys guys i'm
finishing after this game
oh my god is charlie writing
wow charlie just raided with 7 000 plus
i was planning to go in like one minute
but
maybe i can stick around for one more
game if you guys behave yourselves only
because
charlie's the man thank you
let's jump in for a game so yeah to
those of you who were here
before once we win the night the game is
already over thank you suburban
uh yep for the for the tier one the game
is already over obviously and the rest
was pretty self-explanatory
so let's begin we have the white pieces
here
against a 1600 so
oh my god 20 donation from pink magic
here's my last donation of the night oh
god
terrible joke i was about to thank you
but then i saw the joke
so let's go e4 and
we've played a whole bunch of openings
in and thanks thanks for that for those
20 bucks so we played a whole bunch of
openings
in the speed run and as i
said last time the uh the opening that i
recommend
to probably people in the 15 16 1700
rating range is the vienna gambit
the vienna gambit is it never
it almost never fails at this level it
almost never fails to get a great
position and in the vienna gambit which
i've played before thank you
benguino supreme you go knight c3
now to those of you from charlie's
stream um
i'm sure you guys have heard the term
gambit before
gambit is a type of opening when i say
opening that's the first couple of moves
in a chess game the first
approximately 10 15 moves there's no
exact number
but the start of a chess game is called
the opening and there are different
openings openings have names they can be
named after people
so somebody could have played an opening
a million times and that's the
voice critical variation okay there is
no moist critical variation
yet but maybe there will be um
but there are also gambits like there's
the king's gamut and a gambit is when
you sacrifice a pawn
or more to gain something specific like
control of the center
and one of the most important things to
do in an opening
is to gain control of the center of the
board the center is these four squares
that i've highlighted
but these two this is called a file
these two files
it's super important to get your pieces
onto squares where they're basically
controlling squares on these files
i know i'm giving a lot of information
at once and so this move f4
which if you look carefully right it
gives up a pawn
black can just take our pawn with his
pawn
and uh that's called the vienna gambit
thank you jc says for the five wow we
got
way too much hype in here all right
now what do we gain in return for this
particular gambit
this is a very classical gamut in the
sense that we get control of the center
once this pawn leaves z5 it's like the
light goes from red to green
this pawn on e4 can push forward and
attack the knight if he does this we'll
talk about it
if not we'll talk about it after the
game he does it
all right i'm ain't called a prophet for
nothing so
the pawn on e5 right it's moved away
from
that square the light has turned green
this pawn can move forward what does
that move accomplish
you don't make a move that looks good
without understanding specifically what
it accomplishes
well what does z5 accomplish it attacks
the knight and that knight doesn't have
too many good squares to go to
this night has been developed so
development is the process of bringing
your pieces out from their initial
squares
and when you attack a developed piece
you force it to move
if the knight doesn't move we take it
and a pawn's much less valuable than
than the knight he's gotten queen e7 but
i just want you to notice
that the knight doesn't have any good
squares to go to these two squares are
controlled by the queen
right these two squares are controlled
the ones that i'm going to highlight in
red
or green rather are controlled by the
knight so if the knight were to move it
would have to go back to its initial
square that's a huge waste of time
instead our opponent has decided to go
queen to e7
now i'm trying to take the night but i
can't why not
what's going on here now obviously i
know that those of you
who are advanced this is very basic
but um this is kind of impromptu so i
wish i had
if i had prepared these explanations
they'd be more smooth you can't take the
knight because
the pawn is pinned what does it mean for
the pawn to be pinned it means the pawn
cannot move
because if the pawn moves it exposes an
attack against the king
so if a piece or a pawn is pinned
moving it results in exposing a piece of
greater value
if this were a queen right the pawn
would be
legally able to move so if a queen is
the piece that's on the opposite end of
a pin
it's not like you can't move the pin
piece but here you can because it's
illegal
it is illegal to leave your king exposed
or in check
so what he's done is he's immobilized
the pawn
and he's done that because the pawn was
attacking the knight now our goal here
is to make a move so that the pawn
is able to attack the knight once again
we need to unpin ourselves
what does that mean well we need to put
something in the line of fire of black's
queen
that should make logical sense even if
you don't know the rules of chess
there is only one way to do that without
losing the pawn
now you might say okay so let's go
bishop e2 let's put a bishop here
and block the pin but that's not good
right because then the queen can
can take that pawn on a5 which is
unprotected so we have a second thing to
do we need to unpin ourselves and do it
in a way
where the pawn is protected so there's
only one way of doing that and that is
queen to e2
we need to e2 pawn to d4 doesn't unpin
the pawn it defends it but doesn't unpin
it
queen e2 our queen moves into the same
position that black's queen has gone to
and we are once again threatening to
take the knight and win the night
now you might say well what about the
fact that doesn't that hang the queen
doesn't that give the queen up well no
because our queen is defended by a bunch
of pieces
right so it's all pretty simple
all right knight g8 so now what we need
to do is we need to bring our other
knight out
to the best square that it can come out
to
this is very common black is already
lost so trust me the time use
is is fine we are already winning on
this move
if we can find the correct move now one
very common piece of advice is that you
should not develop your queen
too early in the game why is that well
it's very very simple
if you're you know if you're a war
general do you
go out onto the front lines with a sword
and just like i'm going to fight them
i'm going to be the one
on the front lines fighting like no the
queen is your most valuable asset it's
your strongest piece you only send it
out
when the coast is clear if the coast
isn't clear the queen is going to get
attacked by
all of the pieces and without any kind
of protection from the other pieces the
queen is useless it's going to get
attacked going to get sent back to its
initial square
and you're going to waste a huge amount
of time and you can't afford to do that
how can we attack this queen yeah well
genghis khan maybe it may have been an
exception
so we have our two knights developed he
doesn't have anything developed and
that's the difference our queen can't be
attacked
his queen can and it can be attacked by
positioning our knight in the center
knight t5
knight d5 attacking his queen and
there's a big problem that he has
he can't move his queen just anywhere if
he brings his queen up
we capture his pawn that's a fork he's
got to bring his queen back to its
initial square and then we have a
beautiful move
that crushes the game immediately
and um after that we have a move we have
several moves that win
but there's one very cool move that i
think particularly and he just resigned
he now what does that even mean that
means he gives up the game
because he knows that he's already lost
he has recognized that the game is
basically over
it's sad because i don't get a chance to
show the win but i will show it now
sorry that was a lot of explanations in
like three moves
yeah so right now um
where am i in the speed on those of you
who aren't usually in my stream i do
have a youtube channel by the way
it's just my name daniel nerditsky you
can find me on youtube
all of the speedrun videos are uploaded
uh
with a delay right so i did a previous
version of this where i have five
minutes per game
rather than 10 minutes per game and that
has been uploaded in its entirety
i have just a few less subs than moist
does but
if you want to watch more educational
videos on demand you can
subscribe to my youtube i'd be honored
slowly building up to our 200k subs so
um that's there for you obviously i do
these
speedruns live as well so people can ask
questions and then that's uploaded
so anyways knight c3 knight f6 knight f3
of course is is the main move in this
position
thank you f4 um
no of course charlie's the man and you
know
i appreciate i really appreciate people
sticking around um
even though i know some of you don't
play chess very much
um you know so so thanks again
i'm doing doing what i can and five
bucks to ping magic again
all right so f4 is the vienna gambit
now why is it um why is it called yeah i
saw him playing bullet today
we'll definitely try to get a lesson in
at some point um
you know he worked very hard for
pogchamps three so it's important to
take breaks
when you're playing chess but i i
definitely think he'll uh
he'll show his strength many more times
than the chess well thank you zuk the
nuke anyways so
why is it called the vienna gambit well
obviously it's named after vienna
austria
um and usually what happens with chess
opening names is that if it's named
after a city
then there was a tournament held in that
city and in that tournament
people would play this opening for some
reason it coincidentally
like if if three or four players in that
particular tournament or competition
played this move then it would be called
the vienna opening
right because it was played in some
random tournament in vienna thank you
i appreciate it um i don't know what
tournament
this was but that would be my guess i
don't actually know what
what tournament was held in vienna okay
so he takes f4 he takes this is a big
mistake
uh accepting the vienna gambit in this
way is a mistake precisely because of
what we did and i'll get to that
now gambits can be accepted they can be
declined
or they you can offer a counter gambit
you can
you sacrifice something and then your
opponent sacrifices something of their
own
in in return now what does it mean to
decline a gambit well
in gambiting this pawn we're also
attacking black spawn we're threatening
to take it if black just makes a random
move
whoops sorry we're going to just take
black spawn so
what can black do to defend this font
in order to not give it up but also not
take white spawn you can just say i want
this pawn here
and i'm going to bring my own pawn up to
d6 yeah
in order to build this little pawn chain
if white takes
then black takes and nothing really
happens we have a trade nobody really
benefits from this trade yeah chess
tournaments are resuming
slowly but surely you know sort of
postcoded
um i've read it's usually better to
decline early gambits
i wouldn't generalize there are some
which should be accepted
but there's always going to be some way
to decline the gamut and have a good
position
but the problem with the move d6 and
this is sort of high level chest
thinking
one of the reasons that chess is is hard
there's many reasons chess is hard
one of the reasons is that it's it's
there's so many things to keep track of
like you do a lot of thinking in one
direction
and you're like i completely forgot
about this other thing that this move
does
and it goes on and on and on so one
thing that d6 does if you look at this
bishop on f8 right
you need to develop the bishop as i said
at the start you need to develop your
pieces in ways where they control
various squares in the center so in this
case the ideal square for the bishop
would generally be on c5 right here or
on v4 so the squares i've highlighted in
blue
how oh my god
oh my goodness there is no way this just
happened
holy smokes oh my god this i could tell
something was going to happen dekaio
with a
hundred subs damn girl
oh my god that is this is getting
ridiculous
wow it is good to see you dekaio he's
been
uh a supporter for a long time and
you are the absolute man 100 subs
that's incredible
super high energy stuff i don't know why
my alert
doesn't seem to work thank you i really
appreciate it
wow sorry for the bad chess yesterday
i'm speechless well we just got 100 subs
folks
so incredible stuff
yeah this community is is phenomenal
but yeah before i was rudely distracted
by this uh by the suburb
i was talking about something totally
useless which is what i normally talk
about
so i was talking about declining the
gamut
right so the bishop belongs on c5 and b4
thank you to kai i really appreciate
that
100 subs that is a massive bomb right
there
and uh if you think about it the problem
with the move d6 is that it doesn't
allow the bishop to come out to c5
you can't jump over the knight is the
only piece that can jump over a pawn
the bishop can't jump over your own pawn
and so this bishop is limited to getting
out to e7
that's a very passive square so the word
passive in chess just means
a square where a piece doesn't do that
much right you can
it's similar to the definition in like
real life
so there's all these considerations and
so the best move here
is a counter gambit which is deep well
not really a counter game let's move d5
d5 opens up the center thank you
blindfold bolo
and if white takes the pawn on e5 black
snake can swoop in and take white spawn
on e4
if you think about it white's king is
kind of weak
black's queen can come out and deliver
this check on h4 this is a super
complicated position i don't want to
talk too much about it
as i progress in the speeder and i'm
almost definitely going to have
this position on the board so i'll be
able to talk more about it
i think i've already had it once the
best move is to bring the queen out to
f3
and that leads me to one other point
before i get to the game which is that
when you're a beginner you learn all
these rules thank you for the hundred
bits
you learn to develop your pieces you
learn not to bring your queen out too
early
then you're like let me watch how the
grandmaster's playing you watch the
grandmasters play
and you're looking at the game and
they're like what are the grandmasters
doing
didn't he just say not to bring the
queen out too early why are you bringing
the queen out too early
so when you learn these rules the better
you get the more you learn that there
are
a ton of exceptions to the rules that
help you
gain basic strength which is i think
something
that whatever you know if you play video
games
um i'm sure that there is an equivalent
and i unfortunately am not skilled in
any other
game and barely skilled in chess but
perhaps people could let me know but i'm
sure this sort of learning process takes
place where you learn all these very
basic rules about
how to maneuver your character or
whatnot but then the really good players
they often violate these rules because
they've mastered these rules a very long
time ago
and they're basically playing at another
completely different level
um the hillbilly is the new berlin
defense you know any kind of if only
you'd gifted 100 subs
maybe i would have been able to
accommodate your request exceptions
override generalizations absolutely
learn the rules so you can break them
and again i'm sure other games
have these kinds of uh
analogies you know any game where you
can become
very skilled okay uh so anyways he plays
he takes f4 we go e5
and um
oh my god
is this a glitch
oh my god that's another hundred what
this is insane 200
from dikaio
[Music]
this is insane and i had the audacity to
refuse to answer his question
time to talk about the hillbilly
absolutely
now this saint who just gifted these
subs
he is a proponent of an opening that he
has an unholy obsession with
which is e4
c6 bishop c4 this is the hill really
right this is the famous opening he's
gifted 200 subs to make me show it on
the board
i'm fine with that wow
in freaking credible
total madman another hundred
well just another day in the office
folks another day in the office
all right they know thanks to you
i am honored all right
well again i was i was rudely
interrupted again man i can never seem
to finish my thoughts i keep getting
gifted hundreds hundreds of subs
horrible uh toxicity by the community so
he takes f4 we go e5 we chase away the
knight
and basically as i explained
he went with queen e7 to pin the spawn
if he had moved the knight the only
place to move it would have been back to
g8
which is essentially undeveloping the
knight he doesn't have anything
developed
and we have both of our knights
developed this is called a development
advantage when you have more pieces out
than your opponent does
and that's generally speaking a good
thing so we've sacrificed our bond to
get a big development advantage
and better control of the center we have
a monster on e5 just sitting here
controlling these squares
and he doesn't have anything i mean
black literally doesn't have a single
piece though this pawn is sort of
irrelevant we're going to pick it up
later
and uh you know he takes f4 is already a
mistake
queen e7 queen e2 unpinning threatening
once again to take the knight
the knight moves back so we essentially
have the same position except the queens
have moved out to these two squares
this didn't really change too much but
the key difference is that white can go
knight d5 and black can't
after d6 which loses the game knight to
d5 happens
attacks the queen and forces it backward
white has two moves that win the game
one is very simple the other is super
cool
could somebody name one of these two
moves to melinda confirms
that's freaking hilarious
okay so he takes
yeah so the symbol move is e takes d6
this is called a discovered check
the pawn is not delivering the check the
queen is delivering the check
but the pawn moved so the pawn opened up
the queen's check
the bishop has to block for example and
then
you can take the pawn on c7 this is
called a fork attacking two or more
pieces generally with a knight
the king moves and then you take the
rook so and if the queen takes the
knight then the pawn defends the queen
or defends the defends uh the knight so
this is very simple
but in such cases you can often change
the move order
you can take on c7 first but wait a
minute this blunders the knight right
the pawn is no longer on d6 so
queen can just take the knight but if
you're well versed in tactics
you'll find he takes d6 this is again a
discovered check and this time
it's the queen that's going to be lost
not the knight so black cannot take this
knight black has to move the king
white takes the rick white is up a full
rook that's a huge amount of material
and basically the game is over so the
lesson to extract from this is
i mean it's nothing spectacular but it's
kind of nice
um and when you've got two moves that
you're trying to play
one two you should always try to
figure out what happens if i switch up
the move order what if i play the second
move first
and then the first move you know second
sometimes that makes a very big
difference sometimes
you can only do things in one particular
move order here you can do it in either
but that's the the consequences of you
know
of having a big development advantage
you get all this stuff that happens
happens to you if you don't have any
pieces developed your king gets under
fire super early
and um that's what yeah 200 gifted subs
makes the night a little bit brighter
absolutely charlie raid does that as
well
um any questions there's so much to talk
about if you're a beginner
you you know would completely understand
it if you felt overwhelmed at this point
so i you know i tried to cover some of
the basic concepts behind this opening
um thank you ex aloha anthony
speaking on ignoring general rules at
higher level play generally what
another sub by animates you wow what elo
or level do you suggest ignoring
that don't damage the pod social rule
well i would say like
intermediate level like 14 1500
you can start getting a little bit more
comfortable in doubling your pawns and
stuff
if you're if you know why you're doing
it
why not queen e7 oh because the pawn can
take the queen
that's a good thought you're you're
you're blocking um
the check but the pawn controls both
squares diagonally
why queen d and not queen d7 it doesn't
matter
the same thing can happen after both
moves like literally the same position
it changes very little um
yeah let me see
okay do you have my no i don't have an
opening named after me i'm not
nearly good enough to have an opening
named after me
you know uh maybe one day after i retire
will uh revisit that question i will
definitely stream again tomorrow
and uh i'll uh do my best to give you a
good show
so thank you all thank you bruja charlie
for the raid dikaio for the massive
support and everybody for being awesome
let's raid gary good night everybody
take care
and i'll see you tomorrow